Let's go to our caller from the two zero five
area code. Who's calling today from two zero
five.
Hey David, this is John in Franklin, Tennessee.
Hey John, what's up?
So I got a question for you regarding uh,
Fox news and just I guess progressive and
progressive voices going on Fox news segments.
I mean, I understand that you've done that
a handful of times.
I've done it twice.
You got it twice. Okay. Yeah, this is more
related to I guess you recently crystal ball
and you know other folks like E N
sorry, you're breaking up. John. I heard you
say crystal ball and I don't know who else
you mentioned.
I said Michael Tracy and Glenn Greenwald.
Um, you know, they really go on and Tucker
Carlson or Sean Hannity and just need to get
your take on if you believe that's helpful
for the progressive or if you think it's harmful
or if they're really just kind of playing
into maybe Tucker or Shawn's emo as it stands
for that show.
I have not seen any of those appearances.
So the devil is in the details and what matters
is what is the appearance. Like Tucker Carlson
is an expert at framing up conversations in
a way that is ultimately beneficial to his
worldview, which is a sort of non interventionist
right wing, um, with a of at least claimed
anti elitism that whether it's real or not,
I don't know. I mean certainly Tucker is,
is one of the elites in in a sense, I've not
seen any of those appearances. I think generally
Progressive's going on. Fox news is perfectly
fine. I've done it if you're well prepared
and if you can sort of take control of the
framing and um, uh, do a good job in espousing
your view. Not in a way where you get kind
of pushed into a corner and used as a useful
idiot. I think it's great to go on Fox news.
It doesn't always work that way. But again,
th the three appearances you mentioned, I
don't even know all the people you mentioned.
I don't know who, who Michael, the Michael
person you mentioned is a, and I haven't seen
them so I wouldn't be able to say for sure.
But ideologically I have no problem with Progressive's
going on Fox news if they're well prepared
to do it.
Gotcha. All right. Thank you.
All right, thank you for the call. Great to
hear from you